welcome to this video playing pour du
jour for to join 993 is the score no
draw okay so let's see I mean mainline
Spanish yes yeah should I play this
chick arena again okay it's like an old
habit how to hard to give up he fought
and unusually early a form but ok
probably nothing that I can take any
advantage of
interesting yeah and what I'm not sure
what to do now that so it's definitely
nothing that seems very threatening but
how do I play maybe I shouldn't take and
play knight c6 this this this early a a
file opening is a bit a bit weird as
mentioned i'm hoping form play with
night before him something like andy 594
is definitely okay for black maybe yeah
maybe you should take em okay yeah
that's probably both okay yeah we're
thinking Knight a5 yeah let's do that
not spend ages on this more
yeah that I didn't consider really
thought that it looks very weird to give
up the bishop potentially but if I go
here 12 d 8 what's better yeah hard to
say okay let's do one of the two seattle
yet of how to hard to say it's a bit
difficult for him now how much always
see untangling is pieces yeah here I
even have night see form yeah that's a
good position for this night and maybe I
can take the hive at at some point now
with takes takes the night c4 is
protecting a five the e5 pawn
okay if you hand me the special pair on
a silver plate i'm going to take it so
what about the c5 pawn yeah f6 or not f6
trying to totally control that maybe I'm
I'm not sure it can still we have the
night on c4 but still it's probably a
good idea to to cover it now it's d5
poorness is weak and isolated yeah Queen
d7 um if I did not take it by the way
Queenie 7 rook e8 I should at least
think about it for a moment not belief
that poem did everything I mean now i'm
getting the porn probably but but still
that was that was really silly or was
there some some big big tactic point
after takes Queen e7 groupie aight i
really don't see it a queen before I can
go queen before that's funny ok but now
I can just take this right
gathered e5 pawn was was a possible
weakness anyway now it's it's gone gone
really quickly okay I really has no move
right night f4 if I take it then takes
rook e8 queen before nice just about
holding on take second
okay Queen before Jo white resign well
that's that's all so nice he really has
no move right i mean i can really maybe
I can do something here I this is this
is strong by the way I d5 is strong
attacking this and then tending Bishop
c6 now can I kind of sacrifice already
checked let's check this check no I can
take be three though and there's that is
this is really strong young winning a
piece yeah this this whole setup is
really really not not great because I
can take this Bishop on d5 whenever I
want and he says he got a hard time to
coordinate is his pieces now you know
i'm also on be to hear black is really
in excellent shape well the engine is on
minus two yeah yeah it is on minus 2
because this is probably lost ya if i
win the pawn i have two bishops the
extra pond and it's an extra point in
the center that severely limits his
pieces yeah this is of course really
really funny i should at least think
about this for mo qliktech not plagued
this immediately that's that's really
stupid I don't know sometimes yeah I
mean this is also very good attacking
the rook and attacking the night so just
just weird tlk here I'm winning Queen B
7 is probably also yeah enough to win
this but it's of course not not the best
move okay thanks for watching